per adesso ma adesso arrivati a partire
mentre non ci sono aspetta che mi siedo
ma mi stanno già venendo io ho fatto
play a qui non mi stanno vedendo
quindi possiamo mostrare culo si ha meno
male eh eh da qui c'è pietro che mi
stavano pietre ciao momento si sta
partendo lo devi vedere tu è partita ho
capito guarda ai cristiani sta guardando
tutto e che sono state parlando da soli
quando mongoloidi così cosa che facciamo
i prodotti dalla finestra che sono
andati vicini mi rompono al cazzo arrivo
esso nel cimino con i [ __ ] qua
80 gr di due suoi a la merda vi spiego
voi al problema fa caldo fa veramente
troppo caldo però quando io registro
devo avere la finestra chiusa perché
siamo in finestra aperta la gente mi
sente e michele a cazzo quindi i volti
delle finestre e morire dentro l'inferno
con questa luce di merda e con pietro
che emana calore perché dietro per
grazie prego quindi fa veramente un
caldo bestia proprio la prossima ora
avremo tutti un caldo bestia qua dentro
ma giochiamo così suoi siete contenti
noi no però voi sì quindi scattato
stamani era quella di quella commessa
buongiorno a roma molto molto il giusto
per fare la solita figura di merda
davanti a tutti ma il cazzo se frega
jolo
[Musica]
direi che ci siamo ragazzi siamo giocare
dato ho risolto il problema della scarsa
che era così sapete tipo lo schermo
rovinato adesso non è più rovinato non
mi chiedete per quel per quale motivo
rimaneva così nelle altre live però
adesso si è risolto bene tanto che se la
prima live che faccio mi sa da quando è
iniziata l'estate giusto cremis come ve
la state godendo questa estate raga è
già finito giugno
egli a scuola non ci vado da apple e una
scarsa dai pasti andiamo solo sul sul
gioco bello ai vistosi successo quando
lo aspetta la mia faccia
ora la mia faccia chiedere chi viene
buttata nel libro stasio la mia faccia
nell'iperspazio bellissimo bellissimo
addio e geniale poi quindi sotto odiavo
aveva sarebbe fissi guardi i cursori che
vanno nell'indice maraga bastano già
chiamate per il clima sta roba che cazzo
ciao mamma ho preso la lsp ma vabbè
cos'è sta roba
no è bellissimo c'è un chip son troppo
forte ma la scritta ed è bellissimo
dall'ultima volta la faccia poi il primo
ne vado giuro è vera la troveranno gli
alieni non si sa quando però vabbè ci
siamo ragalo reich quest'oggi non c'ho
voglia di montarlo
mi spiego sono tornato ieri tardi da
casa e ho detto dai giochiamo a è più
rischio domani lo monto non c'ho voglia
di giocarlo non c'è voglia di montarlo
allora cosa ho detto facciamo una live
questi poi dopo non devo mandare il
video perché sono pigro e quindi ho
fatto di farlo saranno fatto bene pietro
gravissimi grazie grazie mille facciamo
un primo livello che sia decente oggi
rpg test vediamo che che visuale in hd
ci sarà per questo rpg per pc ha fatto
bene ragazzi livello no però dettagli
justin dover tanto bene come come a ok
ma io faccio è la madonna asquer che
quindi non si sa come ricarica a casa
magia vedi pensa e poi spunta ragazzo
fantastico però melaka vestigia c'è
questa richiedere un sacco di pratica tu
non lo sai pietro però per giocare
questa roba non si vede che non lo so
sacconi tipo negli ultimi cinque anni li
ho passati flap vi sarà allenarmi che
sono col cazzo che sono riuscita vacanza
marcatori [ __ ] però davvero mancato
sul serio va bene va bene dunque
mi fa piacere che facciano questi
livelli ancora sia giusto per dare senso
alla mia vita come se prima non rs water
bottle flip questo ci mette 7 a
proposito e non bravi hanno detto però
abbiamo ordinato un panino che se non
signori deluxe e non so infatti se
dobbiamo ancora mangiare quindi
probabilità arriverà il panino mentre
stiamo facendo la live
se io non lo sento pietro ed aprire la
porta perché se non mangiamo dopodomani
proprio di no che tensione aspettare
questa massa intorno perfetto porcacchia
ciò che tu sarai tra la sua data zero ad
anacapri parla passerà la seta prove
dalla testa della tensione nell'amata
nome bellissimo storico è stato bello ma
no ma vi che a guardare veramente
cercato già sentire ma che cazzo scarica
incasso il casco è rimasto flippato va
bene è finito male questa volta
ufficiale ci prova bene l'ultima e poi
giuro che finiamo allora data di brescia
di cosa felici nel segreto ma è dunque
nube
mi accontento anche di quello io ci si
accontenta anche degli scarsoni parka
erano riesca a prendere l'ultima a
pedali facciamo l'ultimo azzurro a mese
vive li mettono la droga non hai visto
niente
ma questo successo grazie a dio tu non
hai visto mai visto nella guardare dalla
live che agli avanti ragazzi dal suo
riguarda il largo ma [ __ ] il botto
run lo tornar mi sento carico non
guardare quello cameristico sulle
guardando bene ci sono
questo livello quando riscatto non
riesce a farlo su un ribelle sono
pratico tutti quanti noto che hanno
difficoltà a farlo anche sono mai capito
il perché c'è niente di strano sono
riprese dai pezzi era affetta la tattica
per distratti in realtà avrebbe
effettivamente non ha senso colori stava
dicendo botto il film update airbus
rivolto al clip che poi continua
riccardi perché mi viene automatico
tensioni sociali in passato le lenti va
bene già attesi no dai tua madre lei ci
aspetta la persona ma che ci fanno
perché li mettono così basse le
bottiglie se poi saranno annunciati
milano fa riga salva fanno apposta
porca vacca che ansia
[Musica]
no no vabbè basta
ma questa era la vera la vita se usciva
sta roba ragliare la vita ma devo
ammettere devo fare che cosa
la storia board la samp aver quindi
quando succedono certe robe io attacco
vedendo cosa ci dovrebbe essere
finora ci dovrebbe essere lo zoom va
bene non so non so fare e di dignità non
so fare normalmente più gratis o editare
in live
ok è vero non è rimasta in piedi
però non mi abbia già qualcosa l'ultima
porca [ __ ]
oltre a poco tempo fa bene cosa è
successo
lascia molta lasciamo perdere acquisto
vari che il gioco perché gioco brut che
esca il challenger laga e la madonna
cos'è sono enigmista una vita stella e
va bene e questo è impossibile
preferissimo fermi dal cielo riuscire
fighissimo petriano senso è abbastanza
prove come dimagrire in step semplice
vabbè io ho fatto così
dovrei perché so già come i mimi non
dormo la notte per questo qua e tipo mi
dà fastidio mi metto un'inquietudine
addosso che non hai idea porca vacca
stronzo ma ci devo riuscire ormai raga
in live cioè non posso fare figure di
merda poi non posso tagliare e non posso
far vedere che ho vinto
ma picchiasse cadevo alla fine sarebbe
stata una roba tragica va bene così i
ragazzi tutto bene con il presidente si
vede tutti 31mila spettatori che qua
ragazze dei disagiati io ve lo dico
perché non potete essere in 31.000
guardare invece continua a fare sul
gioco nella speranza che la gente non lo
guardi più esattamente per questo
continua porc ai aver sempre per una
volta che non lo faccio e ora che si sta
male youtube della mia live una volta
che non lo faccio porca vacca la gente
vita contro come se avessi dimenticato
non so il loro compleanno quindi lo devo
fare ancora ancora ancora per il resto
della mia costruita vita gioco di me
fendi friendly questo video che riprende
quanto non esiste limbo tornarmene
riesco a farli ragazze l'unico livello
che riesco a fare dietro di sebo torna
quindi evitiamo quello a prescindere
non hai capito quello che ho fatto bene
non è che io però ok naturale per cento
il prossimo lancio per gli imposti come
preciso carico è visto fortissimo carico
però sono ancora ma tu sai io mi tolgo
le frecce dal petto ma sì come il
gladiatore ma questa quest'anno la
tolgono con la fa male per la moratoria
ovviamente è meglio una freccia del
petto che un pianeta e anche questo non
è che sia proprio il massimo e m lato
cosa fare nel culo disegno notissimo
però è se fanno dei livelli che non si
possono finire ma va a finire che lei
aspetta comuni cosa va bene lampada anno
francia in video ma è presidente sia
veramente fastidio
già è impossibile no se come no ma io
non so che chiediamo da un meno solo un
ortopedico
io credo che non sia vivo devo il trucco
è che se ai cristiani perché se sei
cristiano non ti sfoghi nel modo giusto
per fare i militari secondo me questo
non sta soffrendo pronunciò vuole dire
c'è una freccia quale il collo e mezzo
ok ok poi si libera si libera si libera
quest'uomo
tra l'altro mi sono continui fila si
rompe nel culo non so come va bene
vittoria importante che ho vinto
raga e sarà strazianti a giocare un'ora
così perché sarò che sa proprio figure
di merda non faccio tante lo sapete voi
però importante riuscirci il possimo il
pogo ninja come è facile dai come
spiegano in quando riusciremo
la gamba vinto poi non so se vale a devo
arrivare 0 si vabbè il casco il casco
che ha fatto cosa è successo fermi tutti
non ho capito
c'è stato un momento superman o se la mi
sono spiaccicato contro il muro
malissimo come ho fatto a vincere di
vivo everybody's beach bravo zio hai
capito tutto
ma mi sa che con sarebbe figo ma che vi
viene in mente speck e fascista nuova
pranzare
no quello no mi dispiace 0 facciamo tipo
presidente perché mi piace l'idea di
essere di fare le cose giuste in editing
facciamo così aggiungo questa roba di
sottofondo se funziona
troppo troppo troppo casino lettera iva
di gruppo
raga editing il live sta roba che ciao
ok c'è anche una canzone di sottofondo
ti piace stava sentirò bene io con gli
la terra una scusa per averla di nuovo
di inception perché me ne frega un cazzo
della musica insomma per fare così va
bene basta ragazzo so che state per
vomitare pazienza next level aragon next
level destroy di enemies io tengo sempre
a musichetta soppresso questa è una cosa
che a prescindere se io devo far fuori i
nemici con la bicicletta ma state ben
bene infatti tutto l'istruttore tuttora
le due mani luke tutto nelle tue mani
zio
so che ce la puoi fare bravissimo
bravissimo complimenti è proposta una
mousse consenso cosa devono guardare
quello che sta succedendo nel tempo
galan non guarda e non lo fa perché qui
non l'ho fatto apposta dove la musica
mosse la musica che palle
e per me è altissima il ragazzo va bene
urlerò come una [ __ ] ma va bene
pazienza a livello non mi piaceva quindi
cambiato behind the box dimmi se ti va
bene mica come facente qua dentro è
possibile 8 20 hardy
[Musica]
no
un bambino di palestra per questa è
l'aria alle nudità a fare queste cose
non li fisico per quello che vedete
malattia che lo senti famiglia è secondo
me un vero le vostre perfetta sonora
editing live by fa vj and pietro ha
posto grazie fatto 1 per cento possible
by good luck grazie non abbiamo bisogno
sono già bravo hai visto mai visto però
vietato 9 mag ebrei dove era parecchio
ma sono troppo forte e sociali cosa è
successo
pesaro pesaro non ho capito bene la sua
band reggae rock swing ma mi mancava nei
loft l'ing
il latte sai che non ho mai capito cosa
servono i roxy no no no no non fare la
[ __ ]
what i've ha già 2000 diverso ma dai ma
non farlo vogliono far domande non ho
non lo so non più non so cosa ho fatto
non far domande dies io mi sto mica ahia
ahia posso 30 temi si incastrano degli
lei aghi in testa metterla dentro jacket
è stata forte
questa la posizione che favorisce la
cervicale e una cosa che mi dice il
medico
pertanto
[Musica]
per farlo cadere capito che tanto peso
questo è il piatto chiude invece scivola
basta
lui sa quant'è bello questo giocare
ringraziate dio che non le faccio mai le
live grazie guarda dovete ringraziare
veramente la vita su una mi parlava poco
poco dopo c'è in realtà lo tsunami non
dovrebbe essere non dovrebbe essere
fatto con il trita
altri è più il signore e signori è più
in questo è più il spero che siete
contenti adesso permette a musica rock
rock the pineapple anche solo di chiaro
se i robot problema in apple
come dire ora rob la pura lana nella
barca che non ho fatto
prof uomo aia o baciare non ci arriva la
presa e stata la cosa più bella è
dimesso una gamba provo un ananas che
direi che un buon di là di ogni 3x2 tiro
fuori tutto il tempo perché sono drogato
di bottle
non ci posso credere per però non è
rimasta in piedi in piedi ma dai o alla
era niente ance verso prestato figone
bello sorso
no niente pronti non ci ho creduto
no
[Musica]
oddio oddio dio dio di aspetto sedute
doppietta la stretta mag è chiaro perché
un nome possibile sta roba
9 bis trama incredibile non me l'ha mai
successo ma ti giuro che il 2019
successo su 100.000 line grazie
basta le altre non le tiro va bene non
so come ho fatto a farsi arrivato il
giura allora non so come faccia a faccia
roba cioè non ce la farà mai una vita
però va bene la ragazza male come cazzo
fatto guarda c'è la reazione è stata un
po intimidita me no mica ragazza di
incredibile bene bastano le altre non le
top con avanti noti impossible
l'adempimento sembra museo
stop ok è successo l'impossibile ma va
bene secondo me si è fatto male però non
so se guardate qui troviamo a iaia tutta
na lo frenano un po di più che forse
stavolta ce l'ho fatta perfetto cosa
scusa come senza campi o lo yo yo yo
lops
vabbè libriamo
[Musica]
la prima volta che ci ho giocato a sta
roba sono andato di diarrea arca vacca
schifosa aspetta due secondi perché il
gioco ancora questa merda dopo anni con
il suo problema che malattia o ok bene
il prossimo natale per cento nessuno ha
visto niente sono 35mila persone
vai zio secondo me anche alla speranza
in un'altra vita cazzo e reading adatta
mi dicevo perché ci sono quelli che ti
fanno dice che se sei morto si diceva
guarda di essere in judo in live altro
ke ridere ai a niente
[Musica]
beh quelle che arriva il tipo dei panini
sono io sono passati vivo in vigore ma
questa ragione impossibile che sarà
anche possibile fontana sulla sorella
cosa è successo come cosa ma perché io
quando è successo un sacco di volte è
successo un sacco di volte che quando io
tipo tiro un pugno sulla tastiera in
qualche modo esce dal livello non so
come vedi che fa cose giochiamo così
giochiamo giochiamo con tirando pugni
sulla scrivania a caso facciamo tipo non
so se vuoi sarebbe stato figli siamo
bisogna farlo salvare la tizia
e stato un livello difficile molto
tratto un livello molto difficile
mike spyball gli spike sono tipo delle
cose dovete di buttare dentro non così
no non così devi buttare dentro deve
arrivare al traguardo che sa di sotto
però è difficilissimo perché va culo
cosa che io in questo caso non aspetta
[Musica]
stavolta è giusta saltano sento
a dai no no alla sim
giusto giusto giusto
quasi triplo 7 tra l'altro quasi partner
raid 0 quindi miu miu rischiano rock
kings new come se non l'avesse fatto mai
nessuno minchia rock swing e il livello
più vecchio della vita ho perso un
braccio
eccolo in realtà mi serve quindi
potrebbe essere un problema meno male
che non farà uno
andate tutti affanculo ok non ridere non
ride non vale
perfetto ok non so dove andiamo a finire
masticano siamo messi però entrambi
approccio è però non vale una cicca tele
sarebbe figo controllare il personaggio
anche senza la testa tipo bene dell
però non vado
perché non appena le cose ma dai ma che
problema c'e una concentrazione queste
cose le faccio fare un buon casse che
riesce mai a a posto a lesbica no era
gutheim coi denti ti devi affermare
tutta una tua sorella coi denti qual è
il problema cose che non riesce a fare
nella vita uomo senza stare a madara
cafu un caldo bestia non è il caldo
no per niente stai solo morendo io
questa quando sento perché sono arrivato
di culo perfetto e culo la risposta la
cultura ei airbag beni che ha fatto robe
ha fatto lo ha comunque è basato lo
schermo qualcosa fa col olive libero è
chi cazzo li provato dai serbatoi
rimborsi ai difficili si aspettano a
questa l'ho già fatta però
aveva fatto è successo per la riferiremo
sito un troppo difficile va bene che
siamo certi ci aspetta
[Musica]
se vi cadeva in testa rimane validit
ridevo era solo per provarlo sticazzi
dove trovare un impossibile che che non
sarà fatto tipo questo qua l'ho fatto
oggi ancora avanti ecco questo lede ten
è perfetto no non è un imposti col porta
a casa che scrivi impossible
no ci mette un attimo ma lo trovo
tranquillo finisce la merda lo dico io o
prego ma dai
prego allora si sa i tasti allora noi ma
fa vicino però gli sto vicino ha visto
vicino thq ero purissima gravità tassi
così sono andati non lo so ti arrangi
ma come lui non sa vaganti mai prova a
cliccare candido cappa che ho ma che
quando uno va a barra spaziatrice
la norma però ciò che riduce per una
bellezza di doppio intervento la barra
spaziatrice salti no no beh li faccio io
kr attraverso l'evento la z
non devo farla quindi tumblr r
l'aics no iniziano male aspetta
dirigerci scelte ok non è vinto perché
rimuover che magari ora il bello di
questo gioco in tv ma dove stanno
toccando il raffreddore è morto del menu
cercano di tutti fa caldo allora shift
control contro
beh no perché sono perfetta una volta
non va rivolta dicono gli autori vedi
bene è stato bello per farti provata
come gioco abbiamo fatto 150 episodio
buttato via
facciamo un calcio sono 150 episodi e
sono in media di 10 minuti episodio
quindi sono 1500 minuti divisa 60 giugno
con 500 minuti
ho detto allora 150 episodio fatto io
per 10 minuti ciascuno 1500 minuti e
vino 60 del santa 25 ore sotto la voce
no aspetta diventare questo registi che
un contorno un aspetto affatto una
cagata allora aspetta la maturità la
forma conta 50 episodi quindi dieci
minuti episodio se sono 250 sono 1500
minuti saranno solo 25 ore ma di contare
quante giocavano un fondo degli studi a
minchia non è vero che [ __ ] sono
deficiente adesso no
centocinquanta episodi e in media e tipo
si saranno qualcuno più di mezz'ora 40
min 45 95 45 minuti
ducati 112 e 118 un altro 118 fi 112 che
sono 110 ore diviso 24 sono i giorni di
fila che ho trovato questo gioco è come
se andate a cagare va quindi in mezzo a
45 giorni praticamente non ne so fare
sta roba
certi pare bene abbiamo calcolato molto
tempo giocato a sta roba rara
senza contare anche che una volta che ci
troviamo senza registrato lo è allora ho
detto tu stupido ma i cazzi sul posto
continuando a fare l'impossibile che
sono quelli che mi fanno incassare i
profitti o libera scelta non è che
l'ultima è stata una volta è bellissima
è tornata indietro pure la testa non ci
voglio stare qua non ci arrivo perché
ora ci arrivò la spaccata e melissa
busco è stato fantastico
[Musica]
lo stanno capendo è un nuovo tipo di
yoga questo l'argomento come si articola
tutto diventa tutto scemo quando
riprende il popolo ok ciao papà
[Musica]
sono state calmi la presa brutta è che
le frecce me che mi uccidono primi
appesantiscono noi scopriamo dal suo
senza mani fantastico aie e quando in
quanto poi volevo volare alto questo
gioco è una merda sapri championship non
può andare a guardare quanto riguarda i
family friendly disney disney visive
libri che così il video diventato i
family friendly non è successo niente di
quello che pensi allora ma di urlare
anni emergency lealmente con personalità
enes name is joe l'ho mancato proprio
centro c'è un problema di aia e
scivolato
fammi vincere questa partita ne ho
bisogno
non si fa di servizi e di strevi se la
fatica delle due figure
certo è che questa dovrebbe aver fatto
ma non muore ma neanche se ci arrivo
tipo di testa forte di servizi disney di
business
basta a 1 dopo un altro nata una
presenza in prossima per la mia gioia
[ __ ] porta è il nuovo tipo di
creatura mitologica l'uomo arpione l'urp
duomo la cuomo
il serbo torna magari non ferrari days
mi cleese non corri sotto la madre di
barton ha perso il piede noi c'è chi di
noi è spuntato come possibile impongono
wow dal livello pieno di emozioni dalle
viaggiando è qualcosa di decente almeno
non come prima beh questo questo era era
più figo almeno non è disney più o meno
sì grazie
il possible con una tetta no no no
madonna cosa è successo all'inizio era
successa roba incredibile la teoria
dall'inizio ragazzo vuole avere successo
cioè mi ha spinto un arpione a caso
senza motivo vabbè se il 6 per cento
possiamo due magari no diving
ma perché
ma perché no non è specchio figlio mio
figlio figliolo è ora del bagno ma non
ho peccato era un disegno no sarebbe
stato figo
[Musica]
l'altro non è un disegno walk like
spiderman geografica proprio è un gioco
che migliora di giorno in giorno ragazzo
molto migliore the floor islam ha detto
floris family friendly il nostro esperto
sa io devo stare su ok ho capito dossier
sul tavolo
poi con le donne e faccio schifo però
successo su happy days che il mio ma chi
è questo l'importante questa è una vita
mi ha insegnato sempre mio padre
l'importante è avere successo se poi
delle donne ahia ahia
basta sfamarsi il canale youtube basta
stramazza youtube ce l'ha fatta
va bene così raga oggi sono un fire
preti hard e chiare della mamma cosa è
all'aperto e così è successo che prima
non andava bene adesso si formi una
delle persone bene per cento dai aveva
già fatto questo si aspetta
la
[Musica]
porca vacca ci credevo
ma sta diventando bravo faccio perché
magari in tutto il resto ma in questo
sono bravo ragazzo
io vi dico una roba qui un secondo
perché fa veramente veramente caldo non
aiuta veramente se grazie grazie grazie
grazie grazie
se mi mancano bisogno di come questi per
il sudore 15 bass d'oliva vigente
siamo figli di pitagora ed epub jpeg il
caso fare che la fa veramente calmo
ragazzo che il figlio di poco si
capirono un ventilatore non climatizzato
ce l'hai
l'ultimo dittatore ciao avuto fuori da
caldo prima genitori buttafuori aria
calda è una tematizza merda non serve a
niente nella vita però la cubatura bene
va beh sì perché io direi di concludere
in un modo fico fico figo prova fanno il
livello di belen e di blu party così a
caso che come che più mi ha rotto il
cazzo e la filano in un modo o
nell'altro non l'ho voluto fare e non lo
faccio
gli olo mentre a fare bene niente
pilotati faccio un livello solo ma lo
voglio fare bene mi faccio capire quanto
è isterico questo gioco pre fighissimo
allora mentre si avvia magari sofia
qualcosa che ho caldo lasciarci
allargano fa veramente caldo legga i
giornali io non mi dicono non è stato in
cui ha fatto così caldo possono io che
porta a cancia non ci sto dentro
benedetto in esecuzione
non so come tutto heidi king live che
cosa che non ho mai fatto in vita mia
non sono capaci a farlo sono offline
figurati il live
vado a caldo poi è incredibile già da
prima
ecco bravo file quando a selena selena
non c'era ga perché è rimasta incastrata
sotto la scrivania non l'ho presa per
quel motivo e non so aia va troppo caso
non ci voglio neanche di accendere il
computer figurati di tirar fuori selena
fa è un so che fa caldo anche persone ha
però mi sa che adesso me la prendo dopo
due tentativi poco la vetta
[Musica]
ok perfetto
ci siamo veloce sco altro alcune termine
una partita da con qualcuno vediamo e
marchionne va in casa russia né mi sono
chiamati a casalpusterlengo un creatore
della musica perché c'è già mi sono
chiamato a casalpusterlengo non fatemi
domande non so perché jolo dai parchi
parti che qua siam il live non c'ho
voglia di aspettare non parte da tomatis
che faccia questo
ma maschera di salmo perché non parte
con detta un'altra partita su ca altro
che ti dico da tutti a cagare
non puoi ne faccio anche io il game mode
facciamo ma perché perché mari con essa
vorrebbe non ci voglio stare qua partite
strage come partner solare a321 c'è
stata partita
lo sapevo se si è cagato addosso si
risvegliò all together dieci minuti e
dalle webcam e francia webcam con
cronica porca vacca non c'è la webcam è
mica la scusa mi sono stupido adesso mi
sappiamo che si usava the raga ci sono
vicine e adesso bene viper e come
abbiamo fatto in un sorriso ai a porta
che avevamo fatto un solista gioco guai
credimi non sarei mai visto è una roba
troppo
pentire della vita rete di arrivare al
traguardo finale è di collaborare in
teoria ma se come quando un collaborano
nessuno sono tutti uno per uno ma poi
non è per niente pacato è grazie amici
siti che non vogliono stavo dicendo se
sai che mi piace questo gioco e non si
fa certo ma porca vacca mi serve solo
scendere perfetto novara quello dove la
fa ancora non vale
volevo fare un verso sarebbe stato fini
diverso sono molto più belli dei corpi
senza vita che versus tease filipe poco
alla gente come fighissimo ok fin qua ma
posso anche spingere gli altri doverose
[Musica]
corri corri prima che con lo si vendicò
ricordi vai una gamba roma con l'aspetta
bastardo
il sert mar mi insegnerà la carne dai
non so voglio di
di sacrificarmi a marca ma la quale di
tutto il giro del fare che diventa giu
rapporto dai mi sacrifico jolo pieni mi
sono sacrificato per la squadra dai mi
hanno cliccato hanno cliccato perché
perché perché picchiamo la gente a
teatro e la lui lo student center e la
mattina con picchiando nostre serve un
gilet vabbè io sono a cagare non sapete
fare le cose stronzi sbagli start start
please casalpusterlengo
hai niente turn to find the blues in my
live
ok niente ragazze tra gli altri ma i
numeri a caldo amico parti teatro perché
ero tutti i personaggi personalizzato
tutti e io no perché faccio dischi come
si portava incerto ha suonato come scusa
come si personalizza il personaggio per
giorno come siben giornali jefferson
hack solo cibo hanno suonato dai membri
dei panini uomo già fi e un sacco ma
seguenti giochi non so perché che
ragazza che ragazza che gli ho scritto e
ho bisogno di trovare le ragazze nella
mia vita e lei ha detto che la ragazza
if you start ai uil fai
il brand istanti calde dai guai
ora basta
star
guardate come l'ho convinto quella per
me lo ha convinto ad esso è stata subito
sei ubriaco mi ha scritto grande cibo
cibo hai preso il cibo giusto già detto
che dovevo trovare una tipa e lui ha
scartato subito davvero se partiamo
partiamo non ha mai fatto di questo
livello perché al captare anzi vedendo
quante vite 50 grazie a dio sono
cinquanta giovani sono vivo
no graf found volevi che come sta
telescopi nazionali non esercizi ma mi
prima casa ci passo qua jolo jolo jolo
adesso arrivato riportate arrivarci
ancor più velocemente sono incontrato
sulla testa carbonizza oltre ci sono
passato da como e ora era un bel
problema perché in teoria di sa che
dovrei salutare lì sopra e farmi
trasportare dalle eco esatto quello che
sono pappa così non ci sono arrivato per
un niente schifoso a minghia ma perché
c'è chi ci è arrivato riusciva a carmen
sono vivo sono ridotti eroe italiano
sbagliato not make it out quello uscito
avessi capito
ora ho capito usato fare fermi tutti si
è aperta si sapeva dall'inizio aperta
appena portare così per i mezzi però non
ho troppe vite che non sono capace come
faccio sia su quello che devo devo treat
armi per forza hai rotto il cazzo
facciamo così mi lancio la testa jolo la
schiaccia non so non so come fa a però
non ci passa di mano a devo arrivarci
deve levarsi in piedi per annunciare la
testa ok
sì però che bordello suo livello quindi
mi trito e scelto la carne se so perché
da un mese ma questo piccolo non mi
chiedere la fisica nei video di baby va
più breve di non ha senso la fisica nei
giochi in alcuni va a fare una roba ma
non mi riusciva mai poi e per ci credo
no vabbè ma se non dovesse circa 12 mila
volte non mi riesce mai
non so come ho fatto io sono dio mio
parente di giorno sono fatti
che malattia al tipo per aver fatto un
livello così che ci si è messo d'impegno
cazzo della stradomenica fatto un mese e
check point che serve sono svenuto nel
nulla però va bene amiche giro tutte
voto il tiro tutti i trick ora che bello
è maroni cosa ti svegli la mattina
uguale pensi mi chiama il labirinto
store o che figata che passi con la
testa ma se questo livello è fighissimo
di merda difficili quanto pensato per
andarsi a destra sai che non solo deve
andare a cena mi chiama fanno affatto un
labirinto porca caso stanno ora con la
testa girare questo devo accendere che
non ho capito
non lo so
basta quante il trip ante cosa devo fare
le faccende aiuto aiutatemi a ecco veri
ok visto compli misto e non mi sembra
una fa bene bravo bravo ma non rivederli
innanzitutto
c'è allora io non circuito ma non fosse
lascia la testa sopra si prepara che non
ci arriverò mai dovuto arrivare guarda
adesso non è esatto allora di qua dritto
dritto destra dei notri altri alla
destra porco due entrano nel coso
sinistra entra nelle cose quindi dentro
così vado privato poi l'ex rava con il
dritto destra dietro destro e uno
schiaffo dritto porca vacca destra
arrivo insieme destra sinistra adattare
perfetto casacca schifosa quindi come
abbiamo percorso dritto non i nomi di
strade che sei un pezzo di merda perché
lo so non ricordo non è vista destra
[ __ ] capo ce la facciamo
c'è lo scarico dritto
a destra destra di nuovo perfetto ma
dovrei essere arrivato e ci ho messo una
vita per fare sta roba mica scherzi e lo
penso da presa e l'ho preso l'ho preso
l'ho preso come volevi poiché anche di
una vita diceva perdeva in casa che
hanno capito dove il finale ma lo sai
che laggiù quest'anno motosega non mi
serve adesso bisogna vedere opere
cassaglia tematico sta facendo qualcosa
l'altro o mi sta osservando per vedere
come lo gioco che mi ha detto giocando
la so come esatto
no non mi piace prendevo il check point
odori farmi tutto da vedere se è
presente il non saper saltare dritto
ecco quello porca eva
cos'è quello di aprirlo faccio io faccio
io questo è un piede ho perso un piede
ma sti cazzi ora come sta senza chiedere
la yoga allora devo andare lavoro per le
casse no mi serviva la motosega
non so se rischiarlo per le così non
credo [ __ ] serviva veramente la
motosega londra era quando la barca e va
29 vita e occhio tranquillo anche tod's
che abbiamo preso lo rifarei quello che
ho fatto prima e cercare dentro le casse
il bottone essere studiata bene il tizio
sta mappa che sicuramente non c'era una
ragazza
ok
iolo butta là no no sai che se ci
riprovo un milione di volte non ci
riesco però ce l'ho fatta va bene bravi
gli altri sette stati fondamentali ben
chiaro ai ed aspetta a i never found the
[ __ ] now then you buy
[Risate]
va bè ragazzi cento real ai questa
cagata merita la vita al tizio era un
genio
se come sta seguendo da lime il segreto
era un addetto raga io direi che posso
concludere qua è stata bella partita è
arrivato un panino slancio grazie a dio
cioè la pietro è andato aprendo perché
pensa se dovesse andar prende i panini
mente faccio le live sarebbe sarebbe
veramente assurdo perché arriverei con
sushi nota false in un'auto mangiato sui
cimiteri di registra una volta mangiamo
insieme ragazzi non ha un senso perché
che cazzo mi guarda la gente mangerà
però una volta lo farò
vabbè comunque sono contenta di aver
aggiustato whiteboard che essere questa
roba qua e di là passionata posso fare
disegni giusti e niente è niente e direi
che possono chiudere qua raga dai non fa
cagate che sta facendo il culo no non
venga in rosa un pene sembrava poi ho
cambiato e che cos'è una farfalla se è
utile ma anche perfetta bene fare bene e
non è più family friendly questo video
disegni snai che verrà anche se sembrava
anche che va bè ragazzi spero che in
questo video vi sia piaciuto cose deve
riuscirci al momento è un bel like
soprattutto per la [ __ ] di prima lascia
aperte sono in live starò bene perché se
lo sia il segnale di stop artù la rai
perché c'è i controlli da lì io il
controllo e si rischia temi ci vediamo
cosa fa come tenuto minuti possibile è
pagato
poi ha dato scopri che il 31 minuti
questa infatti cui però
come ci segnala 31 minuti al torino
ciao ciao amici ciao ho conservato non
stanno piccolo problema